on revient en france si vous le voulez
bien nous avons choisi de nous arrêter
sur deux événements qui sont pourtant de
nature différente mais pour vous
demander s'il peut y avoir un lien entre
les deux d'une part il y a eu hier en
france plusieurs manifestations en
hommage à sara lee missagh halimi c'est
une une femme qui a été assassiné en
2017 par un homme qui ne cachait pas sa
volonté de commettre un crime au nom de
l'islam puisque il l'avait fait des
déclarations en ce sens mais à priori il
ne sera pas jugé puisqu'il a été jugé
par la justice comme irresponsable car
il était sous l'emprise du cannabis
quand il a tué sarah halimi et puis un
autre événement c'était vendredi un
villejuif où un islamiste radicalisées a
tué à coups de couteau un homme et la
justice est interrogé pour savoir si ils
devaient être considérés comme
responsables ou non puisque cet homme a
des antécédents psychiatriques
comme l'expliqué samedi la procureure de
créteil qui suit ce dossier lors bécue
l'enquète se poursuit et elle se
poursuit sur cet élément essentiel de la
nature de sa radicalisation le parquet
de créteil est en lien étroit avec le
parquet national anti terroriste et il
n'est pas du tout à exclure les bascules
de saisine intervienne si ce n'est dans
les heures qui viennent
du moins dans les jours qui viennent
c'est l'important ce n'est pas d'hier
est un acte terroriste n'est pas exclue
parce que la personne a des antécédents
psychiatriques
alors j'ajoute que postérieurement à
cette déclaration le parquet national
anti terroriste est effectivement saisi
de cette affaire
laurence elle voudrait poser la question
de façon tout est un peu brutal mais est
ce que la justice considère trop
facilement selon vous que les tueurs
islamistes sont déséquilibrés quand on
voit la façon dont les événements sont
traités qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya une
attaque au couteau c'est palais
d'autres premières enfin des attaques au
couteau il y en a quand même eu un
paquet depuis ces quatre dernières
années à chaque fois qu'il ya une
nouvelle attaque au couteau le processus
selon lequel il est traité est toujours
le même d'abord c'est un loup solitaire
ensuite on se rend compte qu'il ya des
fragilités psychiques ou psychiatriques
parce que là on est dans la psychiatrie
c'est plus psychologique ensuite à
bailly s'est radicalisée et puis ensuite
à bas affectivement c'est un attentat
terroriste donc à un moment il faut
aussi regarder les choses en face et
dire les faits tels qu'on les connaît
parce que c'est pas normal qu'on ait les
informations par les réseaux sociaux
avant de les connaître dans la presse
quand on sait que la personne n'a crié
allah ouakbar comme c'était le cas à
villejuif qu'elles étaient habillés en
costumes traditionnels et que
manifestement elle n'a pas attaqué de
façon opportune et d'un à un moment il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont pour que les gens comprennent ce
qui est en train de se passer après il
ya le problème de la psychiatrie ces
sept personnes la fin c'était des deux
dernières stars celui qui était sous le
contrôle de cannabis et puis celui qui
était effectivement schizophrène
ça pose la question du suivi des
toxicomanes et de la psychiatrie en
règle générale or on se rend compte que
la politique qui est menée au niveau de
la santé en france n'obtient notamment
des hôpitaux est une politique comptable
qui de ce fait fait fermer des lits dans
des endroits où on en a cruellement
besoin
on a parlé du dry d'ingénierie qui a été
auquel on a renoncé récemment mais
l'état français les sans alcool mois de
janvier sans alcool pourquoi un beau
pactole ont su assumer mais en fait
l'état renonce à s'intéresser à la
question de l'alcoolémie c'est-à-dire à
ouvrir des centres d'addictologie qui
pourrait traiter des personnes comme
celui qui a tué sarah halimi parce que
je rappelle que c'était aussi un meurtre
antisémite il faut le dire ça aussi il
ya une augmentation de l'antisémitisme
dans notre pays qui est exponentielle
plus 74 74
bon sang il a eu 541 cas d' actes
d'antisémitisme dans notre pays l'année
dernière
donc à un moment il faut dire qu'il ya
une montée de l'islamisme qui est non et
l'antisémitisme qui est très fortement
lié et que tout ça doit être dénoncé et
qu'il ne faut pas avoir peur de dire
qu'il y ait un islam radical dans notre
pays que cet islamisme est dangereux et
qu'il est principalement pour les
musulmans je veux juste vous rappeler
quelques chiffres qui sont les chiffres
internationaux il ya eu 31 mille
attentats ces dix dernières années 31
mille attentats islamistes qui en cause
des 146 mille victimes sur tous les
continents et les principales victimes
ce sont des musulmans donc nous est un
français
notre rôle c'est de protéger aussi les
musulmans de 7 ha de cette attente que
l'islam politique à et qui veut mettre
la main sur les musulmans de france qui
sont des gens comme vous et moi qui ont
juste envie de pratiquer leur religion
en paix lui bat votre point de vue sur
ce sujet oui je crois que vous avez bien
repris les trois problèmes en fait
qu'ils sont la conjonction 1 l'état la
psychiatrie en france avec des besoins
de moyens puisque jamais facile de
traiter évidemment des problèmes mentaux
ça demande beaucoup de moyens et ce qui
en a plus on sait que dans les prisons
il ya beaucoup de gens en fait qui
ressortissent à ce cas là en réalité je
vis des statistiques qui montrent qu'à
c4 4e en 80 % des gens qui sont qui
devrait relever d'un traitement
psychiatrique est ce que il ya ce
traitement d'ailleurs est ce que ya cet
accompagnement est à skis ski à ce suivi
s'est évidemment parallèle du fameux
fichier s la deuxième idée c'est
évidemment l'antisémitisme l'udc est
extrêmement préoccupante et puis la
troisième c'est le radicalisme musulman
qui progresse c'est compliqué de juger
une décision de justice
en tout cas c'est pas de toute façon pas
opportun mais on peut juste s'étonner la
contradiction qui peut y avoir à
reconnaître quelqu'un qui du fait de la
drogue est jugée comme non responsable
alors que parallèlement s'il vous
conduisait sous l'emprise de la drogue
vous êtes jugé évidemment comme
responsable ça me paraît un précédent
même si on n'a pas un droit de chez nous
qui est un droit qui est bâti sur la
jurisprudence réellement autant que dans
d'autres dans d'autres systèmes de loi
on a quand même une jurisprudence là qui
me paraît un peu problématique qui sera
peut-être rectifié en tout cas on
pourrait l'espérer
jacky isabello autant qu'on invoque
régulièrement cette forme
d'irresponsabilité ou 2 ou 2 où on parle
de gens qui sont des déséquilibrés mais
est-ce que par nature on n'est pas
forcément déséquilibrée quand on tue
quelqu'un avec un couteau de cuisine ou
sa religion et donc est ce que ça doit
pour autant
excuser ou exempté de responsabilité je
ne me sens pas en capacité de dévaluer
ce point là maintenant ce qui est
indéniable c'est que le meurtre de
madame halimi est évidemment un meurtre
antisémite que le meurtre de
de villejuif est un acte qui a été fait
suite à la propagande islamiste même si
le monde révélait tout à l'heure que ce
jeune homme s'est converti au
christianisme ensuite au protestantisme
puis à l'islamisme ce qui n'explique pas
maintenant là où moi je me refuse à
franchir une certaine ligne c'est de
dire est ce que la justice est
illégitime dans sa capacité à appliquer
un principe de droit et il lui revient
comme il pourrait revenir aux sapeurs
pompiers de dirai ce que j'en vois des
soldats sauver notre dame même s'il ya
beaucoup de risques
est ce qu'elle est légitime ou
illégitime à dire qu'ils sont
irresponsables et moi je me refuse à
commenter ça parce que je crois qu'ils
sont formés à ça ils connaissent la
manière dont les choses évoluent
rappelez vous cette phrase malheureuse
de lombard qui disait une espèce de mode
suicide en parlant de gens qui suicider
chez orange
là ce qui est sûr c'est que les
déséquilibres et s'il pouvait faire
d'autres choses avant pour porter
atteinte à la société
désormais ils se saisissent des oripeaux
de ce que la propagande islamiste leur a
demandé de faire
donc voilà j'ai pas plus de compétences
mais en tout cas je me refuse à dire que
la justice va beaucoup trop loin dans sa
capacité à évaluer ce coin là et on lui
a conféré cette responsabilité je trouve
un peu dangereux très comme ça
spontanément pour dire ils vont un peu
trop loin comme s'il avait un agenda
caché alors ils ont fauté en
construisant un mur des cons un pardon
des grossiers parce que ça a été révélé
je pense pas qu'ils aient envie de
construire d'autres murs sur sur
d'autres jeux c'était un syndicat
concurrent 64 exalte raturé par
l'ensemble de la de la corporation
vole pas du considère qu'il faut juger
le criminel donc le meurtrier de sarah
halimi qui il était drogué mais cela
n'excuse rien
je nous dit qu'ils soient des équilibres
et psychologiquement ou pas il faut
pouvoir isoler ces meurtriers prison ou
internement un meurtre reste un meurtre
le gouvernement n'est pas assez faire
avec les islamistes ajoute reste
notamment au niveau des mosquées
salafistes
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'il est procuré
que il ya une forme d'incompréhension
entre la justice m'a qui appliquent le
droit j'ai acquise est venu rappeler à
l'instant et et l'opinion qui dit on
cherche trop d'excusés c'est à ces gens
en l'occurrence il ya quand même deux
cas très très très différents un pour ce
qui est du meurtre de sarah leamy des
experts c'est pas les juges là c'est pas
la justice des experts très très pointus
se sont prononcés en disant qu'il était
responsable et c'est la justice qui a
décidé de passer outre cette expertise
donc là c'est ce qui crée d'abord c'est
ce qui permet aux avocats de dire aux
avocats de la famille sara lee me le
dire mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce
qui se passe là donc de de mettre en
place une vraie question
et du coup l'opinion publique se saisit
de sa et di c'est vrai ça pourquoi
dans l'autre cas c'est un ce sont des
cas en cours de d'élucidation aussi bien
mais ça mais s'il ya eu aussi une
affaire comme ça moi j'ai plutôt
tendance à dire mais à partir du moment
où on décide de passer à l'acte nact
aussi violent que de prendre un couteau
et d'aller tuer quelqu'un dans la rue
pour des raisons obscures
justement mais voilà on est déséquilibré
donc
s'il faut il faut il faut aller plus
loin que ça et d'ailleurs depuis depuis
l'intervention que vous avez diffusé à
l'instant villejuif c'est évidemment
c'est à l'évidence une affaire
terroriste et de toute façon il n'y aura
pas de procès puisque le meurtrier a été
tué par la police